you want to talk about the dream on KD
[ __ ] let's talk about it I'll come the
story of these what what exactly have I
first of all Katie was already in the
news a week ago right media [ __ ] you
won't talk about that at all
he basically said the media Steph
Curry's eyes and that made everybody
hate him because they were against him
whatever but then dream on was on some
interview and they played a two-minute
clip of him talking about the KD
situation he was basically like he never
talked to us about it and that made it
impossible for us to deal with like
Steve was like Coach Carr was like let's
just try to have fun this year but you
can't because all anybody talks about is
free agency I think it kind of makes
sense like I I mean like it was probably
a big distraction and you know if he's
saying that that's why they're lost he
does have a point you know I mean they
did lose to a team that Toronto Raptors
who you know they had no free agency
issues I mean none at all right they
didn't have their best player on the
team you know I don't know not for the
next year and you know I mean they
totally didn't have any distraction with
what he was gonna do that's finally
actually leave I mean yeah like I mean
how could you possibly win honestly how
could you win a championship when your
best player is not other contact and not
talk about where he's going Donna I
don't know how is positive valid point
especially if you're so like you're like
an all-time great yeah
like Charles Barkley can't even sit at
your table that's right cuz it'll rings
you're so good you're so good but you
cannot do it in a Finals but you're so
good you still got Steph honestly the
Raptors are so lucky that they didn't
have to deal with a situation right now
cuz that situation would be crippling
you know what I mean like I mean wow
yeah totally man no dream on is a genius
bro like and next-level self-awareness
for real yeah this guy is completely
self-aware like he really understands
not only his team but like the other
teams he's playing and like what they're
dealing with
yeah man he you know that guy's always
been self-aware that's one thing you
could say about dream on hundred-person
who he is he really doesn't understands
how great he is he understands the
problems they're going through and what
the cause and effect is he gets it all
any other sins the real reason why his
team lost yeah he gets it yeah it was
definitely the elephant in the room I
think that's what it was the elephant in
the room
it was definitely KD not telling people
that was probably it yeah yeah man not
him being injured and them not having
the best player on their team yeah you
know but whatever I mean it is what it
is
you know apples and oranges tomatoes
tomatoes whatever should we explain that
we're being incredibly sarcastic right
now or just let it be sure let's stand
let's go ahead and say your real
basically were it's basically we're
trying to say that draymond Green is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that he didn't realize that the team
that beat him had the exact same
situation going on and they somehow
managed to maintain their focus they
somehow managed to maintain their
ability to be a cohesive team unit and
managed to topple the Golden State
Warriors not going say warriors we're
dealing with injuries that's ultimately
that's what probably did it man did them
in but stop acting like this [ __ ]
what did he call it like a black cloud
over the season or whatever it was it's
so funny to me how quickly players turn
into owners when it benefits them
[Applause]